what will happen in the society if we
achieve technical knowledge such that we
can do
the sorts of things we've never been
able to do before
but we
lose the moral and philosophical and
Theological
wisdom to understand when we shouldn't
do certain things and it's not just off
in the future this kind of stuff is
happening right now
I've got to start watching the
Kardashian show I guess the only reality
show I've ever really liked is Jersey
Shore because I just know those people I
grew up with those kind of people uh and
I've got to start watching the
Kardashian show this was one of the most
serious and nuanced discussions of the
issue of surrogacy
that I've seen anywhere on television
and it came from Khloe Kardashian
feel less connected this is not easy I
definitely like buried my head in the
sand during that pregnancy that I didn't
digest what was happening and so I think
when I went to the hospital I really
think that was the first time that
really registered and has nothing to do
with the baby it's just you're like okay
we're having a baby and this is my son
and I'm taking him home with me I
definitely was in a State of Shock I
think from my entire experience
in general
don't stop don't stop I felt really
guilty that like this woman just had my
baby and you're just I take the baby and
then I go to another room and you're
sort of separated like I felt it's such
a transactional experience because it's
not about him
[Music]
I wish someone was honest about
surrogacy
and the difference of it but it doesn't
mean it's bad or good it's still great
okay and then there it is right at the
end
that's the required
endorsement of the sexual Revolution and
all this Progressive insanity
but the entire segment the whole
argument
says no surrogacy is obviously terrible
there's obviously something deeply wrong
with this and here's why
and here's how I felt it and here's how
I bet the surrogate mother felt it and
here's why it's so wrong for the baby
because because procreation is supposed
to be about the baby the only person to
be said to have any real rights in that
is the baby is not us but I've had
trouble connecting with my child now as
a result of this I feel like I just
discarded this woman I just rented this
poor woman's womb and I throw her at and
I take the baby it didn't occur to me
that the natural process of pregnancy
would would get me prepared physically
and mentally and spiritually to have a
baby I didn't have any of that I just
drove to the hospital one day I just
realized oh my goodness I'm having a
baby and it's been so so hard and I wish
people were honest about how terrible
surrogacy is
but I mean it's great though but no but
it's really it's great though I know I
have to say that because I'm a
mainstream figure on television
but
it's not
it's not great it's obviously wrong and
I see why people
have been tempted to do it I see why
it's 10 why all sorts of
Temptations exist people are tempted
toward things that are bad because it
seems like there's some goodness there
or because they feel a little bit
desperate or because they're constrained
in their lives and so I get it I
understand the temptation to surrogacy
but good ends
the good end of having a baby
do not justify immoral means
and when we engage in immoral means I
mean you see this throughout the Old
Testament
some of the greatest figures in the Old
start to cut corners and start to fall
into Temptations and start to say oh
well I can't have a child with my wife
or I'm gonna have a child with her
handmade
we're okay I can't I can't get this
victory that I want okay I'm going to
cut a corner over here and it never
works out things begin to spiral out of
control we are simply not smart enough
to be able to account for all of the
externalities to account for all of the
unintended consequences of these sorts
of things we think we are we flatter
ourselves in rationalist modernity that
we can we can reason through every
single little thing in fact we're far
less capable of reasoning through all of
these consequences than human beings
were even four or five hundred years ago
we we don't possess even the
sophistication that people had then and
then they had a much healthier dose of
humility
and recognized that
it might seem fine on a sheet of paper
to say okay I'm gonna I'm gonna rent
this poor woman's womb she's going to
deal with all the difficult parts of
pregnancy and then I'm gonna go pick up
my baby at the baby store but gosh it
just seems so transactional and isn't
there something deeper to human life
than mere transaction mod modernity
liberalism tells us
that we're all basically just consumers
we're all just economic creatures in a
Marketplace and I pay you for this and
you give me that good in service and the
left believes that and even the right
large swads of the right believe that
but that's not true you can't just make
every aspect of Our Lives into some
economic transaction this is what the
great conservative Edmund Burke warned
about when he warned of the economists
officers and calculators who had taken
over the world these are not merely
economic transactions especially when
we're talking about the relationship
between a mother and her child listen to
Khloe Kardashian she makes a good
argument right now I go to prepare with
knowles.com I love that URL it's
difficult to trust anything or anyone
these days if you've been paying
attention to current events at all these
past few years you know that you need to
be prepared for anything reality is you
might not be able to find food when the
next disaster strikes right now my
Patriot Supply is knocking 200 off their
popular three-month emergency food kit
go to preparewithknolls.com grab this
special deal before it ends your
three-month emergency food kit provides
over 2 000 calories each day for optimal
strength and energy in stressful
situations enjoy a wide variety of
breakfasts lunches dinners drinks and
snacks do not put off your preparation
any longer tomorrow might be too late
go to prepare with knowles.com save 200
on the three month food kit you will
also get free and fast shipping on your
order prepare with knowles.com that is
prepare with Knowles
knowles.com head on over there right now
you know with Father's Day coming up
I've been thinking about how grateful I
am that my father did not become a woman
for all of his many accomplishments the
greatest accomplishment might be that he
gave me my life at least from my
perspective and he couldn't have done
that if he had become a chick without
him I wouldn't be here
while that might be a strange thing to
say we live in strange times so we
shouldn't take the simplest gifts for
granted show your appreciation gratitude
for your dad making the Bold choice to
remain the gender that he was assigned
at Birth with a gift from Jeremy's
Racers right now they have a 30 off sale
on select bundles and razor starter kits
they're 100 woke free and unashamed to
celebrate manliness so this Father's Day
do not just give him any gift give him
Jeremy's razors the gift that says thank
you Dad for being and staying a man
thank you for transitioning go to
jeremy'sraisers.com today to take 30 off
our razors and not 100 off your genitals
if that line still gets me when I read
it and whoever the copywriter is
certainly deserves a raise
speaking of Technology we're seeing
election interference from Big Tech
already
and it's not Trump getting kicked off
Twitter and it's not DeSantis getting
kicked off YouTube or something it is my
friend
the fake ramaswamy being kicked off of
LinkedIn which is I have to say
the most Vivek social network to be
kicked off of that is so I've mentioned
that uh Vivek and I know each other from
college I was an undergraduate when he
was at the law school we were in similar
kind of clubs and organizations to to
one another
um and and so at the time we we didn't
know each other very well during college
but he had a reputation as being just
very type a very meticulous very very
intelligent very serious and ambitious
and successful and he obviously has
proven that he sold a company for a ton
of money he uh attended the top Law
School in the country at least when he
was there it seems to have gone downhill
since then and now he's running for
president he's a best-selling author you
know very impressive guy I just love the
idea that for Vivek his kind of Doom
scrolling you know in his free time is
that he's just on LinkedIn and this very
professional responsible social media
app and he was kicked off allegedly for
spreading misinformation here's why he
was kicked off I was a bit surprised to
get an email noting that my LinkedIn
account had been shut down I wondered
why because Alexa the number of friends
texted me saying they followed me on
LinkedIn that's how they keep up they
weren't able to find me anymore and so
when I had my team get in touch with
LinkedIn here's the response that we got
I'm not kidding I'm reading from this
apparently my third strike was to say
this the climate agenda is a lie fossil
fuels are a requirement for human
prosperity
those are my three strikes that got me
censored on LinkedIn now it's it's kind
of funny and
LinkedIn doesn't matter obviously as
much as Twitter or
Google or YouTube or or Facebook though
LinkedIn is owned by Microsoft so we're
talking about a very big company and it
shows you okay they think they can go
after Vivek right now because he doesn't
have as much name recognition and and so
it they'll get less pushback than if
they went after Trump or DeSantis and
okay it's just this one
think about how early we are in the race
though and already you're seeing these
kinds of shenanigans to me
LinkedIn going after Vivek this way is a
little warning shot it's a little test
shot in the race to see what happens now
we have new candidates in the race
Mike Pence has long been rumored to be
interested in entering the race
Pence has not said that he's running
but he kind of got scooped by CNN here
in that CNN released word that that he
is going to participate in a CNN
presidential Town Hall
a little awkward that they made that
announcement before he announced that
he's running for president presumably
though if you participate in a CNN Town
Hall you are running for president
and uh Mike Pence has gone now on other
networks and he's started to begin the
process of crafting a message for his
campaign
here is Mike Pence going after Ron
DeSantis on Fox Business
I just don't believe it's it's in the
interest of the people of any state for
a a government to essentially go after a
business that they disagreed with on a
political issue I disagree with Florida
moving against uh Walt Disney I disagree
with California moving against Walgreens
because they're going to obey the law
about a board of patience in some 20
States so they're going to cancel 120
million dollar project look at the end
of the day the business of America is
business and and I'm not terribly
surprised to see Disney canceling a
billion dollar contract it's on that's
only going to harm people in the Orlando
and Florida area and and it's one more
reason why uh as a limited government
conservative uh I've said for months now
that I I think both sides ought to stand
down take the victory for parents rights
in the legislature and move on
so this message is probably not going to
resonate with a lot of people at least
not right now the GOP base seems to be
pretty eager for
an aggressive response to the cultural
war that the libs have been waging
especially when we're talking about
Disney down in Florida or Bud Light or
Target or any of these other companies
and Mike Pence is offering a
fairly contrarian argument here he's
saying look the business of America is
business that's a line from Calvin
Coolidge it's in the business of
America's business we don't really want
to antagonize business too much we we
want to be social conservatives we want
to defend our values but we don't want
to just Pummel these businesses into the
ground wait you know and and Ronda
Santos he went too far here this is a
message that to some degree is is being
put forward by President Trump the
difference is that Trump is such a
belligerent cultural figure that he he
somewhat probably uniquely can make both
of those arguments at the same time out
of the one side of his mouth he can say
Mexicans are rapists and murderers and
we've got to deport everybody and then
out of the other side he can say all
right we need to make a deal and bring
the temperature down a little bit and
the other candidates are falling down on
one side or the other so DeSantis is
falling down very much on the we're
going to Pummel Disney into the ground
side of things and Mike Pence here is
trying to carve out a new space for
himself in the race and he's saying look
I'm the pro-business guy I'm the Calvin
Coolidge Republican I am the return to
normalcy that's his argument and it's a
little bit of a long shot argument right
now just judging from where the GOP base
is but I think it's not the craziest
idea for a campaign in that you've got
Trump running As Trump
you've got DeSantis running As Trump 2.0
so they're both running in the Trump
Lane which is it which is a kind of old
right
anti-globalism to some degree anti-free
trade Pat Buchanan kind of right wing
then you've got Vivek he's the outsider
candidate then you've got Nikki Haley
and Tim Scott they're running a little
bit more of a Centrist moderate campaign
and Mike Pence is going to run on a
return to normalcy people are going to
mock it he's not doing great in the
polls right now Joe Biden however ran
the return to normalcy campaign and the
return to normalcy campaign worked out
relatively well for him along with the
institutional advantages that the
Democrats had what a great clip I'm so
glad you liked it make sure you
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel ring that Bell we'll see you
next time